salamualikum' laughed a lot and he's
going to be throwing at me a bunch of
the questions you've written in so stay
tuned in Java
bismillah alhamdulillah Salaam alaikum
peace be with you I'm Eddie your host
and you are watching the Deen show and
we come back no man Ali Khan back on the
Deen show we had him here before he was
the Muslim who turned atheist and back
to Islam you can see that show at the
Deen show calm today he's going to be
here with us in the D show studio
answering some of your questions so
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the D show and in the Deen
show studio I have Norman Ali Khan with
the CEO or the baina Institute I'm Lila
how are you been I'm very good
but I've been good thank you for fine a
time again to be with us my pleasure and
I got kind of on our last few shows we
promised the viewers that we're going to
answer some of their questions sure and
in one of them people go to the Dean
show calm and we kind of were given a
vivid description about Jenna paradise
and I got kind of taken away with that
and we just spun off and we start
talking about the wonderful rewards for
those who humbly tried to do what the
Creator wants us to do living in peace
and harmony with the commands that the
God that God Almighty the creator has
told us to to live by and then we get
Jenna paradise and huh so people go to
the Dean show calm to see that show I'm
going to continue on answering some
questions and we'll start right away
with the first one sure here talking
about how do I shape up my character to
be of what is pleasing to God so the
person has asked about character how do
I get my character right so God would be
pleased with my character sure I think
shaping up character which is a very
relevant question all of us have things
that we need to improve in our character
it requires a person to look deep inside
themselves and say what exactly
do I wish I was doing better before you
even seek more knowledge are you able to
be honest with yourself and be able to
make a list for yourself these are the
things I wish I wasn't doing and these
are the things I wish I was able to
accomplish in my life that's number one
and there should be a list of things you
could eliminate from your life and there
are wish of things a list of things that
you wish you could have added in your
life and of the things you could have
eliminated you have to really now start
asking yourself how do I get rid of this
for example somebody has a problem with
any kind of addiction via drugs alcohol
pornography whatever it may be some kind
of addiction
well these addictions they usually
happen at certain situations some young
man's home by himself he gets from home
from school early parents aren't home
yet he's got an hour and a half to
himself in the house guess what that's
when trouble strikes so you identify yes
I do this bad thing but I do it at a
particular time in a particular
situation so maybe if I change something
about that time in that situation it'll
help me I know I have a problem at home
being by myself maybe I had to figure
out maybe I could stay at school later
maybe you have to need to fill that time
with something more productive at the
end of the day evil deeds are about a
misuse of your time that's what they
boil down to practically speaking is it
too much time on your hands too much
time on your hands not you're not
keeping yourself busy enough I say for
young people especially you brothers and
sisters they need to keep themselves
busy from the moment they keep to open
their eyes until the time they close
their eyes they can't even keep them
open anymore they should be just busy
doing stuff and if even if that's sports
it's okay it doesn't have to be like
your study in Quran all day it doesn't
have to be that you could do religious
activity but anything productive you get
a job somewhere you you start getting an
internship you start doing some research
you get into sports or whatever it may
be but you're keeping yourself
productive the first thing and fixing
our character is getting rid of evil
deeds like I said before do no harm and
part of that is making really good use
of your time I can tell you something
personally about myself my parents left
when I was sophomore in college I live
in New York City by myself and my
parents aren't here so nobody looking
over my shoulder saying hey
June isn't right and I wasn't even all
that religious at the time but you know
what I stayed out of trouble entirely
why because my day began getting right
early morning getting ready for commute
going to work going from work straight
to school from school back to work from
back to work that I used to go back to
the mush didn't study some Arabic and
then go home I didn't have time for
anything else
even if I wanted to do messed up things
I couldn't because I busied myself and
that's one of the big problems I see
today is people have especially our
youth have way too much free time they
don't think they have to do anything but
she says look I don't have no time I you
know I got all these guys calling me I
got three girlfriends the guy says I'm
really busy that means you do have way
too much free time you know this is a
function of one being in horrible
company okay so this is nuts
this is you're doing something you
shouldn't be doing right obviously and
why does it someone the end up in that
situation I argue most of the time it's
because of our company the Prophet told
us re Sato Saddam in peace and blessings
of Allah be upon him and without any
clarity he a person depends on the
religion of his friend our friends make
up who we are the Arabs have an old wise
saying you know only one levanto sahib
beholder come on and tell me who you
spend time with i'll tell you who you
are
that's what the arab seller you know
it's an old wisdom they have that's very
true who you spend time with is a
reflection of who you are you can't say
man I got some messed up friends that
means you're messed up buddy mm-hmm this
it's a reflection of who you are the
Prophet oh I'm a toughy a person the
mirror of their of his brother brother
here also needs friend
in other words looking at your friend is
like looking in the mirror so people of
good character if you're hanging out
your character often speaks of your
character but you're hanging out people
with bad character who are having all
these girlfriends or girls that are
having all these boyfriends then there's
no surprise you end up in those things
exercise how come just to roll off to go
off this for a second for the next
question why is it so hard people get
motivated to go to a football game to a
basketball game to get motivated
sometimes they've been playing xbox but
sometimes you know when you try to
encourage people to get together we're
gonna have a Holika right we're gonna
talk about a certain topic of Islam
come to my house or fat we'll watch a
lecture watch no monatti con you know or
someone else hopefully something better
okay yeah there you go what I'm saying
yeah a lot of times the motivation is
not there the same way it is for
somebody's other things guys that have
you seen this sure I mean there's
different kinds of people HMDA there are
people especially in the Muslim
community now that have found motivation
and they're really driven to do things
and they get really frustrated because
their friends aren't motivated right
first of all you have to be patient with
your friends cuz you weren't always
motivated yourself it took a while to
get you to a certain point right and you
can't give up on your friends you can't
say oh they're not motivated forget it I
won't even call them the next time no
you keep calling them you keep inviting
them
you've pestered them you posture them
and you pester them until you they
finally listen this one time because it
all all it takes is one reminder coming
out of somebody's mouth and by a lost
permission that reminders like a bullet
that goes through any bulletproof vest
and goes right into the heart and it
hits a person it can change their life
my words and your words can't change
anybody but when Allah puts power in our
words he decides one time for this one
person it could be a million people
watching this video but there's one
person sitting there that these words
will reach and Allah decides it's gonna
change their life and he can and if
Allah doesn't say that we could talk to
little blue in the face we could knew
how they some probably a much definitely
a much better speaker than will ever be
he's talking for how long to the same
audience nine hundred fifty years
nothing changes right which means for us
we can't quit reminding and we can't
quit remembering that Allah is the one
who changes people and motivation is
like that it'll come over time like Omer
my favorite example Omar the Aloha did
wasn't five years after he became Muslim
the Prophet started delivering his
message for five years this guy was not
less than little via LAN LAN hole the
question is what was he doing for five
years we understand how he became Muslim
that's a later story but if you ask
what's he doing for five years you could
basically answer that with one word
partying guys going out hunting
horseback riding beating up some dudes
drinking this is what he was doing he
was busy partying so if you call him hey
have a let's have a discussion about the
purpose of life all about the afterlife
or I gotta go
shoot some Spears or somebody knows a
he's busy there are people like that
even today hey you wanna go to look at
nah man I gotta catch a movie no there's
a game is game time it's Sunday
afternoon mm-hmm it's football time and
whatever you know people have things
that are doing but you have you can't
give up on people like that cause Allah
describes their hearts like a rock
that's got water inside and you keep
tapping at and you tap at it you tap at
it and eventually a little tiny crack
and when that crack happens water comes
out just like faith comes out yes
there's just like that faith comes out
so some people it's easy they just
completely transform overnight and for
some people it takes a long time and we
should be respectful of that and not
give up on those kinds of you keep
knocking on the heart hopefully that
water will come out actually tell you a
story a friend of mine don't lose your
time we got the same we got to go to
break don't know your place we're gonna
hear about the story from the front and
more of your questions being answered
here in a Deen show he's really
passionate about what he does so he's
got a thousand ideas every know that
I'll try to put something in his ear but
he's taking this thing by the horns the
first episode of there
show air that means that's when you saw
the full formation coming so so hope
these guys change what's going on
Bleacher combined with his passion for
the Dixon that made any achieve goals
never thought possible Eddie's purpose
with the beams though was to enlighten
maybe similar positions and she was it
is good for him to make up for all those
times that he missed the doing what was
right so that's why he's working extra
time and he continues his struggle to
help he is an example of a gentleman he
is a living puts their mind to if you
want to do it and you have a willpower
you can do it and if you if you have
some support and some guidance it is
possible he's a machine know it to me is
another example another proof of Islam
you know like if someone we do Eddie
in his youth they would maybe predict
that he'd be dead or he'd be in jail or
he'd be definitely and under in the
negative side of life you know but to
see someone change to see that they're
the whole the character changes to see
their this is you know countless changes
positive changes in their life it's a
sign of God please
it was Jenna like it was Jana like it
was Jana like it was Jana you tell it to
my mama mia turn to my papa we've got it
to my sister me if dalitai my brother
latte castilla-la take us higher la save
us from the fire
I love sips from the fire we have mercy
on us
we have mercy on our mercy on us mercy
on our judgement
back here on a Dean show with the CEO of
baina Institute no man Ali Khan and
please continue where you left off yes I
was telling you about a friend of mine
going off of the example of the heart
that takes a time to open up yes so this
friend of mine his mom was Christian dad
was Muslim and he was raised a Muslim
and his mom I mean he's now almost 30
just did not accept Islam she just
stayed on her religion the religion of
her parents very devout Christian and
little by little little by little little
by little and in after 30 years like 29
years she became Muslim I mean she was a
Christian when he was born and for 29
years he knows his mother as a Christian
and at the end of the day eventually
Allah put something in her heart and it
opened you don't give up on people you
keep making to offer them you keep
striving behind them and this is not an
isolated story there are lots of people
like that you know we think when we give
somebody a reminder and they don't
change right away
that man this guy doesn't listen she
doesn't listen she doesn't care we don't
realize when you say something with
somebody it goes inside the ear it's
like it's like getting exposed to
allergies it's it's there and after a
while you react right it's like that you
could sit there and simmer and simmer
and simmer and eventually it comes out
of this long that's actually what
happened with Amla the story of almond
he heard his LOM way back early on he
heard it from the Prophet himself he
tried to beat up the Prophet one time
with it before he was Muslim
he hid behind the veil of the Kaaba at
nighttime it the veil is black the Kaaba
is black and he's hiding that it's
completely invisible there's no light
lighting at the time and the Prophet was
praying and he hid behind it until he
snuck right in front of the Prophet so
the Prophet doesn't even know that he's
praying that the guy guys hiding behind
the veil is about to jump out and attack
him the Prophet was praying and reciting
Quran and he decided and he's listening
to the Quran he thinks to himself this
is beautiful
wow he must be a poet he didn't say it
he was thinking it and the Quran says oh
ma whoever coldish I'd it's not the word
of a poet the Prophet didn't hear him
but this was the next verse that he was
reciting the next ayah that he was
reciting almost how do you know that he
must be a mind reader the next verse
as well Maha Kali Pahadi Hanukkah and
it's not the word of a mind-reader
Kadena Matata : how little you like to
remember how little an effort you make
to truly remember Dawn's elumen Ramadan
I mean it's the revelation from the
master of all worlds so he's thinking
it's just in his mind he's praying
reciting the verbatim word of God yeah
and these are coming out these are
coming out and he's hiding behind the
veil the problem doesn't even know he's
there he got so terrified he ran away
that's actually not the day he became
Muslim
he's just who's so shocked by what just
happened he came to attack the problem
so I saw him he ran away he met he
became oh so much after that but you
know what the first crack had already
been caused and it only gets bigger and
bigger like a dam you can't cause a
crack it gets bigger and bigger and
bigger it's like that you know so we
shouldn't underestimate the words of
reminder people might dismiss it at the
time a lot of times people dismiss
advice because they're too full of pride
at the time if I try to tell my sister
something my cousin something my uncle
something come on don't bother don't
don't waste my time they don't want to
look like they're listening because it
might even be why should I make you feel
like you won I have to listen to you who
do you think you are and maybe once you
left there like yeah he was right I
should have listened to him but they
can't let you see that because it's a
matter of pride now right it's okay
don't you know we don't have to give
people advice and they transform their
lives because that transformation is not
up to us but we do have to continuously
remind this is the teachings of all
prophets prophets didn't see change for
decades sometimes and Allah what's the
advice that Allah gave to our messenger
so I saw you're not gonna find a better
speaker you're not gonna find a better
message you're not gonna find a better
audience that understands the message
directly the caleche imagine people that
hear the best message from the best
teacher for 10 straight years and still
don't listen can you imagine what an
impossible audience what does God tell
his messenger but the kid in demand tell
mother can just keep reminding your job
is just to remind so it's not our job to
convert or change someone's heart that's
on the Creator but ours is just too
sincere sincere considerate reminder
consider it means you care about that
person you're not just there to tell
them they're going to hell you're not
there to tell them they're wrong you
care about them like you care about your
own child you care about your own
brother you care about your own you know
and they're in the sense here
brother - because you have the same
father Adam and Salaam so they are your
brother and your sister in humanity you
know that that's the reason Allah told
us we come from a single parents so we
think of each other as family so it's
that caring concern a lot of a lot of
times people give advice in a way that's
very insulting yo sister you're not
wearing hijab don't you know that's in
Islam what kind of Muslim are you that's
how you would if your mother wasn't
wearing me that's how you talk to her
there's a way to talk to people right
this is what the prophets taught us how
to talk to not just what to say but how
to say it how considerate we have to be
in delivering a message because that can
soft in people's hearts you know Lena
local uu keidel Kulu the Arab says the
softness of the hearts can become the
prison of the hearts you soft in
somebody's hearts that's like it's like
they're in your pocket now you own them
and that's how we'd understand they say
people are enslaved to excellent
behavior you behaved excellently with
someone and they are yours they're yours
this is what the Prophet was ours at all
it was excellent with people one of my
favorite stories of the excellence of
the prophesy sanam is when he conquered
Mecca when Allah given victory in Makkah
the custodian of the the Kaaba the you
know the Kaaba has a key yes
I was almost wreck and refused to give
him the key I'm not looking it's
Muhammad if I knew Muhammad was a
messenger I would have given him the
keys not a messenger I ain't giving him
the key so one of the Companions grabbed
the keys room without telling the
process and grab the key from given to
the Prophet to open the Quran they
opened it he prayed etcetera and they're
coming out and an ayah was revealed to
give the key back to the mushrik and
apologized to him for taking the key
from him in that way and when he saw
that behavior from the Muslims he became
Muslim amazing it's incredible like
Allah revealed to them look at the time
of victories these are people that were
torturing you and they didn't torture
him or kill him or stab him he just
snatched the key from him and the key
doesn't even belong to he's a mushrik it
doesn't belong to him but all I didn't
like then Anaya comes down and that's
the I actually I shared it about today
in Omaha
yeah Morocco and - am I not Allah Allah
commands you to give the rights to those
who deserve them oh my god
is a great example of mercy mercy
courtesy respect some of the great
people that the people that people look
up to exactly I was Anna degrade or
somebody's other war hungry people they
would have chopped a man's head off
yeah can you a naive the key back it's
it's an unprecedented scenario look at
how the prophecy there was a Jewish girl
she died a young girl she died and her
funeral profession procession was
walking by and the Prophet was sitting
and he stood up out of respect and some
other company he said that's a Jew and
he said what she's not a human he had
courtesy for all human beings how he sat
alone
this is what Muslims have to learn to be
courteous to each other and to be
courteous to all humanity respectful
this is how you invite people now let's
talk about this word for a man we have a
few minutes the word Dawa the word we
use the word on what we have to give
that word to some you have to give it
our twist on right Dawa literally means
invitation now outside of calling people
to the religion have you ever given
somebody an invitation to your house for
dinner for lunch come over to my place
what we'll talk is it possible you
insult someone make someone feel little
insignificant worthless and then invite
them to your house and even if you did
would they come it's impossible isn't it
the very word Dawa means that you have
extended respect courtesy kindness to
somebody else so much so that you're
ready to invite them to your own home
that's what Darla is if we forget that
basic meaning who are not able to carry
this message to anybody we're not it's
not about the arguments it's not about
proving whether God exists or not or
whether this is correct or that's
correct or this text about that all
that's later all that stuff is there the
first thing is an attitude of inviting
people to something beautiful just like
you have a wonderful meal at home I want
you to share I want to share it with you
there's plenty to go around
and what an amazing meal the more we
share the more it increases instead of
going down you know that's why I want
you to share I want more for myself and
more for you that's the beauty of this
religion and we Muslims shouldn't lose
sight of that it's very tragic that
we're losing sight of that but so we're
gonna take another break sure continue
on with another question God
Charlotte here today's show don't go
nowhere
[Music]
[Music]
Oh show us the way to other screens this
is the D did have a smell this is the D
did have his
[Music]
it's a way of life brought to us bad the
messenger best of me again show us the
way to Allah's grace this is the Dean
Dean a nice man this is the D D nervous
[Music]
back here on the Dean show would know
kondeh CEO of Baena Institute and we're
going to continue on we got some
questions here one of them which is I
have a hard time grasping the concept of
final decree other than Islam
several ways I mean this can never be a
short conversation as you know
predestination of God already knows what
I'm gonna do how is it my fault that God
is all-powerful then I'm not really
doing anything somebody and and if
someone has a hard time understanding
that you know if it if it's the first
problem it's if God's under complete
control then I can't be held responsible
if somebody was having a conversation
like that with me the first thing I do
is slap him what you slap me like it
wasn't me it was God's decree you can't
blame me for that because it was
predestined wouldn't work would they buy
that would they be happy with that
no because now I'm saying it's not my
fault bro God's decree they even know
that at a practical level this makes no
sense
they know that but you know why they
believe it or they want to believe that
or they want to argue that because they
want to do some bad things and didn't
want to be held responsible just like I
just did something bad and I wouldn't
really do that but I'm demonstrating
that they don't want to be held
responsible that's the that's the
psychological root of this problem the
second thing I share is I have a lecture
online somewhere I don't know how
everything I say ends up on YouTube but
every lecture there somewhere on the
story of adam alayhis-salam
because the quran does not make a
chapter out of decree rather the Quran
teaches the lessons of decree from the
story of the first human being teaching
us that if there was one human if there
was any human being that had the right
to ask hey you already knew I was gonna
end up on earth what do you mean I ate
from the tree as punishment I got to go
on the earth you already knew all of
that if there was any human being who
could have argued God's decree is
entrapment who could it have been
Adam is around we learned the solution
to this problem in the Quran from other
- I mean history says like our careful
study of a story little by little is
very important and at the same time you
know what Shaitaan said oh you planned
this whole thing against me
ah you made me slip so the one who says
God decreed me to slip is who the devil
the devil
the one who says I was the one who was
wrong a Bonneville and vasana we wronged
ourselves not God warned us we wronged
ourselves if he doesn't forgive us and
shows mercy will be from the losers the
one who admits his own fault is Adam the
one who refuses to admit his fault and
says God's faults is the devil the devil
that's what we're learning in the first
human beings story no surprise they call
this the oldest problem in philosophy
the devil wants to continue what he has
failure he wants to inflict inject that
virus into us it's the oldest problem in
philosophy because that Shetlands
problem predestination Wichitans problem
you know the third thing if somebody is
really philosophically inclined you know
some of our use our listeners our
viewers they can understand simple
arguments and that's enough for them and
some are very very deeply
philosophically inclined and they like
to read you know deeper literature on
these kinds of things for them there's a
book I recommend a friend of mine
actually a senior in our community in
Dallas I wrote the book he's a
sociologist an anthropologist a Muslim
scholar by the name of salahuddin he
wrote a book called God Islam and the
skeptic mind I think it's a fantastic
book I read it on my trip to London I
had nine hours to kill and it's it's a
collection of discussions that college
students had with him about their you
know skepticism our belief in God
predestination shed er etc etc and he
collected all of them in one book just a
transcript of those conversations it's
very very well done I really appreciate
it and I think for like especially
college students and and you know
students that start having problems with
Islam philosophically wants to take a
couple of philosophy courses in college
that book is a great great resource
what's it called again
God Islam and the skeptic mind by
salahuddin we were with our brother
Chris and I don't know if you remember
and he has the same question to you we
were having lunch
mm-hm and you gave an analogy a story
can you share that with oh do you
remember the show I remember the a and
the B yes the two lists in the party yes
I can share that analogy
that's actually the way my teacher
explained it to me because I used to
have the same question and you know
people different different people are
satisfied different ways I was satisfied
with that explanation I with that also
okay so I'll share with you now imagine
that I'm throwing a party yeah and I
make two guest lists people I'm gonna
invite guest list a and guest list meet
guest list a I just it's secret these
are the people I'm gonna invite and
nobody knows who's on this list nobody
knows it's a secret list guest lisby is
open and i say to people if you want to
be on b here's what you gotta do I give
them a few to-do lists and if you do
these things you can get on guest list B
now here you are you want to come to my
party you got two options
maybe I'm on guest let's say I don't
know or maybe I should try to get on
guest list B if you say well I'm not
gonna bother trying to get on B I'm
probably already on a you know what that
proves that proves you didn't really
want to go to the party that bad because
you're gambling aren't you but if you
say you know what maybe I am on a but
maybe I'm not but I really want to go to
this party what should I do
whatever tasks there are to get
guarantee my spot on guest list B this
is basically how guidance works
predestination works Allah decides is
gonna go to hell and who's gonna go to
heaven there's a secret list but there's
also an open list do this does this you
got you get on guess let's say and
there's some people a lot of decide to
guide they're over here amazing thing
you get to the party guess what you
realize your name is actually on both
lists and all the people who signed up
on B were already on a and all the
people that did it sign up for we
weren't on a either meaning Allah and
what mysteriously guides some people but
those are the people that do the right
things anyway
Allah mysteriously decides some people
don't deserve guidance well you know
what they're the ones who actually don't
do anything to deserve guidance anyway
so both of those things what in
philosophy you could say it's God's will
and human effort they come together in
Islam they come together and the way
they come together Quran where this
whole thing comes from is actually one
word in the Quran it's in the fatiha
yokka Mustang we say the word we are
gonna stay
which translates your help we seek or
only your help do we seek your prom sure
you've heard that translation before
then we understand in Arabic is
important here different kinds of asking
for help I'll very quickly explain if I
had a flat tire and I sit in the car
listening to the radio you walked by I
said hey buddy could you help you change
the tire please I'll pop the trunk for
you and I sit in the car while you're
changing my tire that's asking for help
but that's a pretty [ __ ] way of
asking for help now imagine I had a flat
tire I got up myself
I pulled out the jack I'm trying to
crank up the car but I'm not strong
enough you walk by I say handy you look
like you work out come on help me out
over here
I put effort in and then I asked you for
help
that's called nasty Asterion oka I'm
putting effort in already and now on top
of that I'm asking you for help you know
what we learned for that the only time
you and I have a right to ask Allah for
help is when we do what first put effort
in if we don't put effort in we have no
right to ask God for help this is what
led us over and over and over again the
Companions go all the way to the Battle
of Badr the Angels arrive after that
then the angels are not there ahead of
time saying it we've been there since 3
o'clock where you guys been no no you
got to make the effort first then the
help arrives what happens with the
Brahimi son he's thrown in a fire first
then it's cooled human effort first
allows help later but though both of
those things come together and that's
essentially what predestination is once
you put the effort in a las a las
decrees that you will be guided last
minute that we have for our brothers in
humanity the not-yet Muslims and even
the Muslims who now they've been away
from Islam yeah and they are coming back
they watch some of our shows they're
like what we have to say what advice do
you give to them to the not-yet Muslim
and the Muslim some of the basic things
I can do right now to get back on track
or to get on track number one you are in
the opportunity of a lifetime I mean
gosh if you make dough by now if you
repent to God now and you change you
just you don't even do anything in you
just sincerely turn to God and say I'm
turning back to you I'm gonna change my
ways for you then you are in a better
position than any scholar any worshipper
any Muslim on the planet why because
your slate is entirely clean that's what
Doba is
and not only that Allah adds another
incentive maybe you have this endless
mountain of sin behind you and you're
wondering how could I just get rid of
all of that God's promise he takes those
mountains of sins for you like I you
bundle along say yeah team has a not so
little for COD 25th surah those are the
people the ones who sincerely repent to
God or turn back to God he will take all
of their endless mountains of evil deeds
and convert them to good deeds just
because they repented so not only are
you starting at zero sin you're starting
at billions of good deeds because all of
your billions of bad deeds have actually
been converted just from that one act
this is the opportunity you're sitting
on and Allah knows the one who
procrastinates the one who holds back
and what describes that person on
judgement day and that person says
they're about to go into paradise and a
wall is dropped and they're like what
happened we were gonna come and then one
of the first responses of Allah kanakam
for that to man for second what Allah
busting you put yourselves on trial you
kept yourself from coming forward and
you procrastinated you said I got some
time after this weekend one last party
then I'll change one more Roma Bahn then
I'm good one more well just a little bit
more just a couple more semesters and
then I'll stop your word that you were
the people that procrastinated so well
it's dropped you can't be from us
anymore
so this is the opportunity you have to
have yelled now you have you and I have
no time left there's no time like now to
make make tawba so don't don't think you
have time left
I shouldn't think I have time left this
is why the prophets I saw them used I
mean look at him his status compared to
us he used to make the what to Allah he
used to repent to God ask Allah for
forgiveness hundreds of times every day
for what reason because he knows and
even all first of all if a mistake has
happened it's converted to zero and all
the mistakes are turned into good deeds
why not ask for forgiveness all the time
great advice thank you so much for being
with us for finding a time inshallah we
my forward to have you back again so
happy as promised it's all light as it
shot a lot thank you if I were in
Chicago I gotta come by yes yes
something and beautiful advice beautiful
advice why you have life before death
reaches us take that time now to repent
to seek forgiveness from the creator of
the heavens and earth asked for guidance
as the creator of the heavens and
harvest said that all of my slaves are
misguided unless I guide you this was
the crater saying you can't be guide
unless God guide so ask for his guidance
ask for his guidance and then be
courageous enough when it comes to you
when the truth comes to you to be on the
truth to live on the truth and had died
on the truth give us a call